I imagine that at this point in time not
too many people need an introduction to
the trolley problem that gets used in
ethics and also in moral psychology and
other related fields but we may as well
do a little bit of review very quickly
so the classic trolley problem is a
moral dilemma you see that person there
and he's got a lever which changes the
track that the trolley would run on the
trolley is by default running down the
track where it will soon run over and
kill five people but if the person pulls
the lever he can save the day in a
certain sense for at least those five
people by having the trolley go and run
over the other person who's tied to the
track the question then is what should a
person do when placed in such
circumstances
the trolley problem has given rise to a
lot of discussions in moral philosophy
and in related fields and it's also been
an incredibly fertile spur or which we
call it catalyst for memes and this is
actually one of my favorite ones right
here those of you who are up on meme
culture will no doubt recognize the this
bad boy can fit so much X in it meme
going on here and I think that this is
really fitting for the trolley problem
because there's there's people who've
made whole careers out of it I actually
don't think of that great of an example
or a dilemma myself but I can recognize
that you can sure get a lot of mileage
out of it
here's the second meme and this actually
ties into a variant of the trolley
problem in which you don't switch the
tracks but instead push a fat person off
of a bridge onto the tracks thereby
stopping the trolley but producing that
person's death in order to save the
other five people and I kind of like
this one because it doesn't say well you
know do you push the fat guy off instead
it says well you're a fat guy or a fat
person do you push the fat person off or
do you jump yourself and that's actually
one of the possibilities in that variant
of the problem at least if you're
somebody sizable like myself
here's meme number three and I
particularly like this one and that's
why I selected it because it frames
things in terms of utilitarianism which
is one of the standard approaches to
these sorts of problems right but in
this case it points out one of the one
of the issues that arises so it says
Michael experiences pain and pleasure
far more intensely than normal people do
you see Michael just loves killing
people the joy it brings him outweighs
the suffering he causes by far as
utilitarians we surely need to agree
with his decision to pull and this
illustrates one of the big problems with
utilitarianism that often gets tacked
about as a person being a utility
monster if we're going to measure things
in terms of utility meaning the overall
pleasure in pain what do we do about
people who have extraordinarily high
levels of enjoyment in things that we
would say aren't particularly good well
that doesn't help us solve this one now
does it
here's another interesting trolley
problem meme that is playing around
further with utilitarian ways of
thinking about this and and maybe also
bringing up some deontological ones as
well here's the the situation they say
five people have been put in a medical
coma and secured in a device that when
triggered by the passing trolley will
cause precision drain damage such that
they will be reduced to the state of a
contented infant they will be well cared
for an unaware of their change in mental
state on the top track is one person
who's fully conscious and will get the
full gruesome death by trolley
experience should you pull the lever do
you pull the lever so what do we we got
here we've got the five versus one but
it's no longer five deaths versus one
death now it's people who are going to
wind up in a state that they don't even
you know recognize the change in it and
they don't perceive any damage being
done to themselves it seems that from a
utilitarian perspective we'd probably
actually prefer that the five undergo
that them that the one undergo the
gruesome death but if we look at it from
other perspectives we might say well you
know we're transgressing some right so
this is an interesting little wrinkle on
it isn't it
Meem number five that i selected is even
funnier I think there's at least if you
enjoy dark humor so there's a mad
scientist who's obsessed with trolley
problems and he's devised one and given
you the lever the trolley will run over
five people but if you divert it it was
instead travel back in time and kill
Philippa foot before she can propose the
original trolley problem do you pull and
of course I mean you know if we consider
this from utilitarian perspective it's
really no different than any other one
but the fact that we are you know
playing around with time-travel and
saying maybe we'll destroy trolley
problems altogether by eliminating the
person who originally formulated it
there's something else going on there
that's kind of funny
number six shows us the adaptation of
one dilemma to another dilemma both of
which are you could say 20th century
classic dilemmas this has to do of
course with Sophie's Choice where a
woman is given the choice of whether her
one child or another child will die and
is told if she doesn't choose then both
will die and there's a way of
representing this in terms of trolley
problems so you can divert the trolley
towards your son or towards your
daughter if you choose neither both of
them will die what do you pick and this
is indeed a terrible dilemma to be
placed in from utilitarian perspective
you'd you'd have to pick one of them but
from a deontological perspective you
might end up having both of them die
because you refuse to choose
now this is a really interesting and
telling one I think so you've got five
people lined up on the tracks either way
and you've got the lever and the default
is that the trolley rolls over five
people that you love and you can change
it to run over five people that love you
so starting off who do you value more
the people that you love yourself or
people that love you the same issue of
whether you pull the lever or not comes
up here as well and it's not clear
exactly how you should decide between
five of one and five of another I think
to some people it might seem kind of a
no-brainer well obviously you should
save the people that you love or else
you don't really love them why would you
pick people who love you instead but you
know it's kind of an arbitrary thing
maybe you don't love them for the right
reasons or you know it's very subjective
isn't it that's just the mere fact that
you happen to love these people as a
reason to give them priority
here's a particularly funny variant of
it obviously there's no trolley yet
there you've just got you people are
hanging out on the train tracks you
usually hang out on do you ask to join
the large group which seems more fun
join the singular person for a more
intimate connection or does your social
anxiety force you to just go home
obviously if your social anxiety does
that you're better off you can evade the
problem altogether but otherwise it
looks like you're going to be stuck
there on the tracks with somebody and
the good that you thought you're
generating well it's in the hands of
somebody else who maybe you'll flip the
lever or won't
for number nine I thought that I would
select one that actually has nine
different parts to it and this is I
think most of you will recognize and
alignment chart that's originally coming
from D&D but has been turned into so
many other things in meme culture so
let's run our way through all these
different alignments we got lawful good
I want to save you but I cannot commit
murder so they don't pull the lever
neutral good I will save you even if I
have to go to prison for this taking it
on themselves and then chaotic good a
good deed every day saving the five
people by tripping the lever and killing
the one lawful neutral keeps their hands
off of it says sucks to be you chaotic
neutral heads all switch tails I want
that general as in fact what a chaotic
neutral person would be like and then
true neutral notice they're not even in
the thing they don't take any position
whatsoever I think it gets really
interesting when we get down to the evil
part because usually with these trolley
memes the assumption is that we're
trying to do as little harm or as much
good as possible or we're not trying to
not break some day ontological norm or
something like that so lawful evil go
trolley go they're gonna stick with the
situation as setup but they're cheering
it on neutral evil says hello police
there's been an accident no problem I
can wait here should I use the lever so
that ambulance trolley can safely
approach on the upper track they're
gonna create even more damage to other
people finally chaotic evil multi-track
drifting multi-track drifting is when
you screw around at the lever in such a
way that the trolley will go down both
and kill everybody so this is kind of an
interesting meme for it as well
so this 10th trolley meme is a really
great way to end this first
consideration of all the many memes that
are out there and I think it's you know
it's really quite brilliant in every
version of the trolley program you
always know how many people are tied to
both tracks you can tell where the train
is headed and you can tell what will
happen when you pull the lever who told
you about these facts
nobody so what's the conclusion you tied
those people you set up the situation
you are the villain of the trolley
problem you know Alistair McIntyre
points out in one of his essays that
whenever we have a genuine moral dilemma
it's always because somebody in the back
story screwed something up in some
fateful way and I think we can see
trolley problems as an example or a set
of examples of that sort of dynamic and
we should think about our fascination
with these problems the fact that we're
constantly generating more and more
variants of these and piling new memes
on top of other memes and that these
proliferate what is our fascination with
tying people to train tracks and then
coming up with all sorts of ideas about
what's going to happen to them and who's
going to decide on what basis what's
going to happen so these are you know
some interesting thought-provoking
questions to consider these are just 10
out of the vast variety of trolley
problems that I've seen myself and I
know there's got to be hundreds more out
there that I haven't seen and people are
constantly generating them so if you've
really got a kick out of this I'm game
for creating more 10 trolley problem
memes with a little bit of explanation
or examination of them so you know you
can leave a comment or give it a thumbs
up or whatever it is that you want to do
maybe share it on some of the sites
where people
kick these problems around and yeah I'll
keep at it
you